the maker of the popular video game for
tonight faces more lawsuits from
celebrities for allegedly using their
famous dance moves like have lovi and
you can't help but start dancing Fresh
Prince of bel-air stall star Alfonso
Ribeiro is suing for tonight's creator
epic games over his iconic Carlton dance
Latimer Gucci a our streaming network
cbsn it's following the story and
explained who else is making similar
claims when Alfonso Ribeiro created his
Carlton dance on the set of the 1990's
sitcom Fresh Prince it became an instant
pop-culture classic it's now one of more
than 100 dances that players can buy in
the wildly popular video game fortnight
and at around five bucks per dance it's
earned the game creators hundreds of
millions of dollars in a lawsuit Ribeiro
alleges fortnight used his dance without
permission or compensation and he isn't
the only artist to file suit against the
game's creators Instagram star backpack
Kidd is also suing for allegedly using
his dance called the floss and rapper to
Milly filed a suit over his dance the
Milly rock we talked to him last month
what would make it fair for you was mine
business and entertainment lawyer
Merlin Jean Louie says lawsuits
regarding ownership of these dance moves
can be tricky there's a lot of case law
suits are surrounding the copyright of
music lyrics sounds is a full body of
case law related to that but regarding
core graphic works that does not exist
no case law yet we also reached out to
Epic Games but have not yet heard back
Ribeiro does not have copyright to the
Carlton dance but says he was in the
middle of copywriting it you better
hurry up and I could see why you'd be
annoyed John what would we have to pay
to see you do that figure
millions and millions